so now what if we wanted the center
somewhere else how would we actually
move it around okay we can draw another
arm let's draw another set of axes over
here so if you had a circle like this
right we already know I can change my
radius by instead of saying one over
here I could just make it a square and
that will make my circle as big or as
small as I like right but if I also want
to not just change the size but also
change the position if the center was
well what do you think might be some
good letters to call the center H and K
would be great letters we've been using
them all the way along okay I can state
the equation of this by saying if it has
a radius of our right you could again
you could draw that same radical
triangle in you're still gonna get R
squared on the right hand side just like
I had 1 squared or 183 squared or
whatever okay so because I'm moving H
units to the right I won't have x
squared anymore will I what will I have
instead something's gonna get squared
right it's gonna be the X and then how
did you change the parabola yeah how you
change the parabola later how you change
the hyperbola you said minus H that
moves you H units to the right yeah
then have a look what's next plus y but
I actually want to change the Y value
right yeah here we go y minus K squared
this is a circle that has radius R and
Center H comma K
okay now so far we've done the circles
part of circles the semi circles
wrestling question very good so H and K
because they can be any number right in
case you didn't catch what rest and said
H and K can be zero and zero right if
there were zero and zero then let's just
put it in right you get X minus zero
squared plus y minus zero squared equals
I screwed but look what happens to this
doesn't this once you cancel out the
zeros doesn't this just turn into this
guy over here because you don't need to
really when you subtract zero you just
get X right okay now we will come to the
semicircles part of circles and
semicircles in a minute but before we do
that you need to get a bit of a handle
and some practice with this so I
apologize this is not in your I couldn't
find a good one one that I liked in your
textbook that's on canvas so I'm gonna
direct your attention here so have a
look at question one and you can see
what it's asking you for is rather than
okay
here's an equation like tell me where
things are it says here are the features
here are where things are can you tell
me what equation I should get we're
gonna do the first one together right if
we know the center is at 0 0
what's the left-hand side of the
equation gonna look like we already have
a circle with Center 0 0 right yeah see
here's the 0 0 and it just turns into x
squared plus y squared
yeah the radius in Part A is 2 so what
should the right hand side there for
bigger okay
can you guys have a go at our b c d e
and f have a shot let's start having a
look how do you draw these things cuz
kind of a separate skill all of its own
we're really good at drawing parabolas
now like we've been doing them hundreds
and thousands of times circles not so
familiar so have a look at this guy
right firstly let's just get the
equation down right so I'm gonna read
the left hand side this part I'm gonna
read it from the the center right where
the corner to the center they will tell
me where these bits are right so I'm
gonna start with an X do I have a minus
4 plus it's a minus and I get the X
corner from here right so it's 3 very
good there's a plus in there
and then when you're doing why take away
negative to that's why plus to the
negatives will cancel this so I'm going
to get Y plus C or squared what's on the
right hand side yeah so it's 2 squared
which is 4 fantastic all right now I've
got my equation how do I do this
reasonably accurately well what I'm
gonna try and do here is I want to work
out before I put pen to paper I'm gonna
try and work out where should I be and
then get important points on here just
like when we were drawing like oh where
are the x-intercepts
where are the y-intercepts they're gonna
be helpful ok do I suggest on the resin
or a question okay so in this case right
the radius is the square root of this
number this is this guy here for is R
squared just as you can see over there
right so that's why the radius is 2 does
that make sense
cool so Center actually don't is the
first place I'm gonna start we know
where the center is it's at 3 comma
negative 2 so go ahead make sure this is
reasonably accurate cuz your scale is
gonna matter here I'm gonna go 1 2 3 and
then 1 2 so where those two sort of come
together which looks to me about there
that's my center of my circle 3 comma
negative 2
are you following with me so far so far
so good like a now do you remember
sorry just look up at this for a second
do you remember when we did the first
circle on our page we did the unit
circle right and my suggestion to you to
draw it accurately was to draw just
watches carefully so I don't like the
compass points like going top bottom
left right and then make sure you sort
of somewhat pass through all that's
actually not bad cool all right so those
four points will help you do this
accurately now we can do the same thing
with our four points here okay
where will the top and bottom be if I'm
gonna have a radius of two how far will
I reach upward I'm gonna reach up with
two units but look that that there is
two units I went down two to get to the
center but now I'm going to go up two to
get to the highest point are you
following so far so I'm gonna put a
little cross there that's the top
where's the bottom
yeah I'm gonna go from here down to
negative four so I'm gonna go negative
three and therefore BAM there we go top
and bottom of the circle and I will go
through the same process to do the left
and the right will I get all the way
over to the y-axis I don't quite make a
dua because I'm three units away and I
really want to go to so I'm going to
draw that in there you can see I already
have the points on my axis to measure it
and then the last one I'm gonna go two
units to the right so what x quarter
will that be from three I go two units
and I go to five four
there we go so if we drew this
accurately you've got a good scale there
you should look in like oh I've got sort
of the extremities of a circle now you
can join this thing up okay so I'm gonna
get something away this now if like me
it looks like my scale is slightly off
so it looks kind of elliptical so I
could have done better than that and if
you have a pair of compasses you can do
this precisely unfortunately I don't
have a whiteboard size
pair of compasses with me okay now I'm
actually going to skip from this which
is question 2 I'm gonna go straight to
three state domain and range because we
know how to state domain you mean it's
like where does this thing go where is
it where is it drawn let's think about
domain first we can say that X is going
to be within this is a really good
example of where we can use interval
notation okay so yeah I can see here
this is my horizontal domain here right
the leftmost that I get is one what's
the rightmost that I get it's five isn't
it from 3 1 to 4 the radius goes over to
5 so I'm gonna have 1 comma 5 am I
allowed to be at the edges 1 in 5 the
boundaries are they include or not hmm
we are there we're totally like we said
from there the center guru tune it's
that way so you get all the way to one
so which kind of what do I put there
square brackets aren't there yeah you
care with that that's the domain so
horizontally I can guess one two five
and I include the boundaries
what about range we're interested in
y-values now help me up so zero is here
and negative four is here but we tend to
write which so those are the right
numbers but we tend to write interval
notation from yeah from the smaller
values to the bigger ones so that'll be
from negative four up to zero does that
make sense and it's it's still going to
be the square brackets right because I'm
still allowed to get to those edges
Russell that's really good question I
actually haven't thought much about the
order I've never seen interval notation
written in reverse order before yeah you
know what park that question I'm gonna
go see if I can find any way that it's
been written about the order of it but
yeah being that every single time I've
ever seen it I've seen it in from lesser
to greater I probably write it like this
as a safe bet okay